they're saving lives during the pandemic
but tons of discarded surgical gowns
masks and medical waste are polluting
our environment so what can we do to
prevent an ecological disaster this is
inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
elizabeth puranam disposable masks
gloves surgical gowns just some of the
medical items which have become part of
our daily lives since the pandemic began
two years ago but much of the protective
personal equipment or ppe is made up of
single-use plastics that can't be
recycled and have to be disposed of
carefully the world health organization
says all that medical waste is hazardous
to our health and to our environment
protective gear syringes vaccine vials
and chemicals end up in landfills and
waterways the who is urging all
countries to improve their medical waste
management
one of the really important findings is
that we found that covet 19 has
increased health care waste loads in
facilities to up to 10 times current
volumes
um and we you know if you consider that
two in three health care facilities in
the least developed countries didn't
have systems to segregate or safely
treat waste before the pandemic
you can just imagine how much burden
this extra waste load has put on
healthcare workers on surrounding
communities especially where waste is
burned with the release of daxons and
freeruns
well as we mentioned earlier there's
been an enormous amount of medical waste
since the pandemic started the who
report found most of the 87 000 tons of
personal protective equipment ordered
between march 2020 and november last
year ended up as waste the environmental
group oceans asia estimates nearly 1.6
billion masks went into our oceans in
2020 the massachusetts institute of
technology says the pandemic could
create up to 7 200 tons of medical waste
every day
and a study from the university of
portsmouth found masked litter increased
by
nine thousand percent in the first seven
months of the pandemic
well let's bring in our guests now in
new delhi is vimblene duja an
environmentalist and founder of
sweatshirt a non-profit environment
organization in beirut is ziad
abhishakar founder of cedar and
environmental that's an environment and
industrial engineering firm zia develops
the necessary technology to treat waste
and in amsterdam we have yap de vries a
science medical journalist who's
covering the pandemic extensively a very
warm welcome to all of you and mr giles
start with new and new delhi we've named
just a few examples of the impact that
we've seen medical waste have on the
environment but how much would you say
that covered 19 medical waste has had on
waste management systems
so we have to understand that
kovite-based and or say biomedical waste
in general
has short-term medium-term and long-term
impact on ecology and therefore on human
health and public health right now in
case of india we've actually seen uh you
know there's almost doubling of
biomedical waste in in certain areas
we've seen a very inefficient management
of biomedical waste that that's been
happening like we only have around 200
centers that actually are supposed to be
treating biomedical uh waste in that
sense and you know imagine a country of
almost a you know a billion and a half
people and only 200 centers uh to really
treat your waste so it's a it's a very
huge problem where we're actually
addressing the immediate covered problem
uh a pandemic where we're where we're
trying to protect ourselves but in the
process of protecting ourselves
immediately we are actually creating an
intergenerational crisis an ecological
crisis and a public health crisis and
that's where we've seen there are
several visuals coming from different
parts of the country where there are
there are leaps and mouths of
of garbage all around and our garbage
and waterways and we know that in india
those mounds of garbage existed long
before the pandemic began if i can come
to ziad abhishakar you know there are
really two issues that we're looking at
here is one is the biomedical waste that
the pandemic has created is it being
disposed of correctly and then the
massive amounts of waste that has been
created
because of the pandemic whether it's
hazardous or not how much of the clover
19 medical waste you know that's being
produced
would you say is recyclable
well
in principle if you follow good
management practices
everything is recyclable
your main obstacle here is that you are
dealing with a huge
influx a huge volume
and where
you have hospitals that are in charge of
some of this
waste being produced and the other big
chunk is the
regular residence
i i know for a fact that
masks and gloves also you know when the
pandemic started everybody was thinking
that you could transmit it by touch
and
and it survives on surfaces so everybody
was
was abusing uh disposable gloves
and you have the uh the masks
uh all these are plastic uh or plastic
uh materials and in principle they are
re recyclable we we have developed
technologies to recycle these
the problem is can you really properly
channel them to recycling centers or not
and that is and that is what the
conversation today is about the roomland
i can see that i'm not sure if you were
um disagreeing there with zia labishaka
i will come to you in a second but just
before i do i want to bring yop uh da
visa in here because it's been nearly
two years since the pandemic began it's
a pandemic that you have covered
extensively why do you think that the
who has brought out this report at this
time
well the issue has been raised before by
several institutions but it's it's not a
coincidence i guess because we are in in
many parts of the world moving from the
more acute phase of all these different
waves that were very acute all of them
into what they call the endemic states
in other words we're getting used to
having the virus around and we're no
longer in that stage of okay we have to
sort to sort out this crisis and we'll
we'll
take care of the garbage after that
so we have to
come up with sustainable and systematic
solutions now so yeah it's no
coincidence okay and then
if i can bring you in now because i
could tell that you wanted to
say something earlier
so the thing is that you know the
recycling is not a solution in fact uh
you know we what what is recycling it's
about disintegrating plastic it's about
incineration we'll have to really look
at our governments and our institutions
to think beyond pandemic there was a
time two years ago when there was an
immediate emergency response right now
we are prepared but the unfortunate part
of this preparation is that we are still
not yet prepared enough to to oversee to
understand to really manage our ways
we're actually manufacturing yet another
public health crisis for the future
generation and that that vision is not
really clear for our governments we just
have had our budget announced couple of
you know just yesterday and there's no
mention of biomedical waste or waste
generation and the link is that it has
if i can pick up on a point that you're
making because you know i think um you
know when we're talking about masks and
perhaps disposable masks are the item
that we have used most during the
pandemic um the w.h.o says that in 2020
something like 3.4 billion disposable
masks
were thrown out each day a lot of these
masks are made of plastic so why are you
saying that they're not recyclable
no so we need to understand from a basic
environmental policy what is recycling a
lot of recycling is incineration which
is basically again toxins we need to
understand that recycling is the worst
thing when it comes to environmental
virtue of course as there's no other
alternative that we actually have uh
than incinerated there's nothing else
that you can actually do other than
burning plastic but my issue therefore
it is that a very philosophical
understanding of recycling which is the
last thing the last virtue
or of or an environmental virtue in that
sense and we've seen who talking about
it we've seen several health
organizations and public health
organizations talk about it that we need
to really understand that it takes 450
years for for a mask for a simple mass
to decompose it might take just a few
seconds in an incinerator but
incinerator is not the best option so we
need to really have a holistic
understanding of garbage waste
collection like for example in india 75
of our budget actually goes into waste
transportation rather than actual waste
management it needs to be really
critical to grave understanding of
garbage that we need to have well let me
put that to the other shackle because he
does have a very good understanding of
waste management um he you know develops
the
technology to treat waste
do you agree that
recycling masks is just not an option i
mean are they more environmentally
friendly ways to get rid of some of this
waste
first of all let's agree that
incineration is not recycling when you
burn something you're not recycling it
recycling you know in the the the
entomology of the term is that you are
putting back this material back into
practice there's a cycle you are you are
following when you burn it when you
incinerate it you you just lost it okay
no we're not talking about uh
incineration here and we uh you know i
mean you can uh you can just look up
what we have been doing lately in beirut
you know we are in the midst of a severe
financial crisis and a lot of uh
of people now are resorting to stealing
the manhole covers the steel manhole
covers and my organization since april
now we are using uh
facial masks disposable disposed of
facial mass and a plastic matrix and we
are extruding them and we are making
plastic manhole covers
so uh
no uh
recycling is definitely you know if
you're a technical person if someone you
who understand the behavior of plastic
plastic is a fantastic material that
lasts for
hundreds of years all you need to do is
put it to good use and definitely do not
incinerate it definitely all right um
some of the other issues that we have
here is that the
um messaging from the who it certainly
has developed if not changed it's
developed a lot over the course of the
pandemic as they get more information
job devries i want to ask you you know
there's how important are the guidelines
from the who is classification from the
who for example the who is saying that
many facilities many countries at the
moment are
classifying a hundred percent of the
waste of the clover 19 medical waste
they are generating as hazardous which
has resulted in you know places like
wherein lindujas in new delhi the number
of the amount of waste quadrupling in
delhi during the height of the
second wave in may um so how important
is classification and that
that facilities that countries follow
the w.h.o guidelines
well they've been regarded as very
important throughout this pandemic we've
seen it also from the medical guidelines
and
they um
they have to be practical pragmatic so
if you
make everything um
the mo give it the the most dangerous
classification you end up with way too
much if you put it too low
the bar too low a lot of workers health
workers and other workers are
in danger if i look at my own situation
in the country here we have a lot of
self
testing and everybody is just putting
their positive tests just in the normal
waste
nobody cares seems to care about it
but the people that are picking up the
garbage are in danger there so to say
um
so and there has has been no discussion
about it right and and you know and and
on the need for discussion you know
there are when i was reading this report
there were some who recommendations
which actually surprised
me as you know a journalist who's tried
to keep up with all the changing
guidelines the who actually recommends
for example
it doesn't recommend the use of gloves
for administering vaccines but this
appears to be common practice again
we're so used to seeing healthcare
workers in full ppe including gloves so
is there enough you know is there more
re-education that's uh that's necessary
right now
yeah a lot of countries have been
slow slowly moving into more and more
use of ppe
and now we're now it's the time for what
who calls rational use
and that can be
the gloves is one example so you don't
need to wear gloves according to who
when administering vaccines in many
countries it's been done so that's
something to address and they can
so abandon that practice
but it's it's the same for for other use
of bpe it's so that's one of the things
so one of the things is recycling one of
the things is more
um
better waste streams the other thing is
so
um it's rational use so it's it's not a
simple solution it's the swiss cheese
again as we have with the with the covet
again as well with the coffee
the pandemic
like all these different steps we need
to take in order to to solve this
problem
yeah absolutely not a simple solution
vimlenduja you know you work again
in
in new delhi around communities which
living in proximity to poorly managed
landfills waste disposable sites which
there's no shortage of what kind of
guidelines or recommendations would you
like to see from the who now at this
point
so you know as i said earlier as well
you know india currently uh just six
months ago was actually producing almost
230 tons of kovid waste a day
plus 600 uh tons of normal municipal
waste so we anyway have been dealing
with municipal waste issues uh you know
a very fractured waste management regime
and then we have this covered base my
recommendation to who is to really have
an a linkage between between waste and
public health because who is not an
organization which is only supposed to
respond to covet it's also other
diseases so covet or covet prevention is
actually leading to more and more
diseases for future and in fact our
waterways as in right now we know that
in 20 years with kovid waste plus
plastic the amount of garbage and
plastic that's going to enter our oceans
in 20 years is going to be three times
small so i think it's also a
responsibility of who to look at not
just a short term response measure
reaction correction to covid but also to
understand it long term that how do we
actually take care of public health
where we might be able to be safe from
covid by buy a ppe kit or a gloves which
now they say it's not even needed how do
we actually solve this public health
crisis for 30 years 40 years 50 years
because each of this garbage is going to
remain in our system in our ecology in
our food chain for at least at least 400
to 500 years and that's what i need and
i expect wha to also respond to a future
plan a medium-term long-term plan waste
management and public health crisis
management and mr abhishakar what is the
role of you know national governments in
this because the who can of course issue
all the guidelines but again somewhere
like lebanon where the country is in the
political the economic crisis that it's
in and it's had a waste management issue
for years now
exactly i mean and this is not just for
lebanon i'm
i'm a great believer in local action you
know
when you have problems the best way to
solve them is to
rely on the common intelligence of the
community
in pulling resources from the community
and going to the decision makers and
saying this is what we want this is what
we need make it happen uh
always uh relying on um
on outside factors is is is just a
a way to delay the the solution or to to
kind of look at it from a lazy
perspective uh
all the problems that we are seeing now
are lessons for the future
and the the biggest lesson that we
should be learning is that we have to
act locally and swiftly
and to
uh also uh
train a lot of our of the population we
have to make them aware that you know
this is also bad for you this is not
just good for the environment this is
bad for our collective health we need to
deal with these kinds of materials and
these kinds of kits in in a more
responsible way and local governments
have the responsibility of placing the
right infrastructure in place
we we heard now that even in amsterdam
they were throwing away the the
self-testing kits with the with the home
uh with the home garbage this is this is
utterly unacceptable
uh jupta frieza what is the level of
awareness in amsterdam um you know in
the netherlands and other european
countries when it comes to disposing of
when it comes disposing of medical waste
but also the impact that it's having on
the environment
well
in in countries like the netherlands
sector the the real like the basic
medical waste that's been processed from
the the hospitals and the municipal
health stations there the vaccine
streets as they call it that that's kind
of okay
um
and and that's that's kind of it's under
control but there's the huge
environmental issue i was i would argue
in favor of some kind of global
uh cleaning day for for all
the whole world population together to
clean at least the mass that we have now
because it's
people don't seem to care i mean a lot
of people even make fun of of leaving
their face masks in the weirdest places
this is more of a fun game than of of
responsibility
well it certainly sounds like we're
going to need a global clean up day um
vimlainduja one of the things i you know
really want to cover in on this is
plastic production it's more than
doubled since the start of the pandemic
you know how concerning is that for both
the short-term impacts of that on fresh
water on oceans and then of course the
longer-term impact of nanoplastics
staying in the environment
so indeed as in you know we're talking
about plastic and then we are talking
about microplastic and that's where we
talk about whether we incinerate it or
whether we we actually make it into a
bucket or a product or a plastic sheet
all of the plastic is going to remain
into our environment plastic always
through recycling also only downgrades
into a lower quality plastic in that
sense i think it's it's going to stay
it's going to be really important that
it's disposed properly you know and
that's where the role of the governments
is very very important to realize that
biomedical waste efforts or biomedical
waste management and disposal facilities
needs to be improved as i said earlier
we only have 200 of them in in a in a
billion and a half people and they're
almost one quarter of our country
doesn't even have that facility so
therefore we need to really have an
integrated plan where we look at corona
slash covid we look at public health and
then we look at public ecology plastic
will remain in our in our in our lives
and through our food chain if we don't
respond to it right away we have uh just
a couple of minutes left in the program
and i'd like to ask a very quick
question
to all of you the who report says that
it's not an either or choice between
clover 19 and the environment but how do
we reach that balance uh mr abhishakar
i'll start with you in beirut
well you know this is not the first time
the
humanity experiences a pandemic you know
we've we've been having them for the
last 20 years
again and again and again and it's
always going to be the same thing unless
you have the proper infrastructure in
place
for a pandemic and for non-pandemic
related waste issues
you're going to be facing the same
problems all over again it's it's the
role of local governments and local
communities to put the pressure and to
put their act put their act together and
start putting down that infrastructure
yop the visa
yeah i would agree with that that the
infrastructure is the most important
thing it's to stop ending up
with plastics from ending up in in
oceans is is to stop from stop them from
from ending up there so that's the most
important thing and and
then and the report is is is pretty um
extensive in in in giving all these
different
other steps that need to be done like
some is recycling some is um
different new materials more sustainable
materials so but a lot of work needs to
be done all in all these fields okay and
uh
see in a common sense civilization we
should have woken up in two years it's
been two years and still we don't
realize we don't understand and we're
not acting or we're not giving
proportionate response to this waste
crisis my only expectation and
suggestion is that pandemic is not over
and we never know it's been around for
two years if you don't know how many
more years it's it's going to continue
we need to really create systems at
least this is a trigger warning for all
of us and our respective governments to
really invest in biomedical waste in
invest in in in waste treatment and and
in our public health therefore all right
mr john thank you very much for that and
thank you to all of our guests
in delhi ziyad abhishaka in beirut and
yap davisa in amsterdam and thank you
two for watching you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter i'll handle this at aj inside
story from me elizabeth ferrano and the
entire team here bye for now
you